Hi.
Welcome to recitation.
Last time in lecture we graphed
some trigonometric functions
and some inverse
trigonometric functions.
And there was a slight
error in one of the graphs
that Professor Jerison did.
So I just wanted to
talk a little bit
about it and about
what the problem was
and with the correction is.
So the function in
question is the arctangent
or the inverse tangent.
And so I like to write arctan,
where Professor Jerison usually
writes tan to the minus 1.
But they just mean-- they're
just two different names
for the same function.
So the inverse
function of tangent.
Now I've got a
graph set up here.
And what I've graphed
are the lines,
y equals x-- that's
this diagonal line--
and the graph y equals tangent
of x-- so that's this curve--
and here I've got one
of the asymptotes of y
equals tangent x at pi over 2.
Right?
So as x approaches pi over 2
from the right, tangent of x
shoots off to infinity getting
closer and closer to this line.
And, you know, it does
something similar down here.
And then of course,
it's a periodic function
so there are many
copies of this.
So one thing to
notice about this
is that the tangent
comes in here.
The graph y equals
tan x comes in
and it is tangent to the line
y equals x at the origin.
So the slope of tan x
is just its derivative.
So we saw in an
earlier recitation
that d over dx of tan x is
equal to secant squared of x.
And so the derivative
at 0 is secant squared
of 0, which is 1 over 1
squared, which is just 1.
So the slope is 1.
And in fact, a
stronger thing is true,
which is that for positive x,
tangent of x is larger than x.
So this falls away.
So you can figure
that out, for example
by looking at the difference
and higher derivatives
if you wanted to.
So the result of this, is that
the graph of the arctangent,
that is what you
get when you reflect
this graph across
the line y equals x,
and because of the way
these graphs-- because
of this property
that this graph has,
that it lies above the line
y equals x for positive x,
when you reflect it what you
get is something that lies just
below the line y equals x.
When you reflect this whole
picture, that the piece,
this piece gets reflected
and comes entirely
on the other side of that line.
So the height here
will be pi over 2.
That'll be the
horizontal asymptote.
And it'll come below-- so
this is y equals arctan x.
So it will come below that line.
And similarly, over here it'll
come, it'll be the reflection,
so it'll come above that line.
And again it has an asymptote,
horizontal asymptote,
at minus pi over 2.
So the one feature
I want to point out
is specifically these two curves
only intersect at the origin.
So in the graph Professor
Jerison showed you,
they looked more
like square root
of x and x squared, which have
a later intersection point.
But here, for x bigger
than 0, y equals
tan x is always bigger than
x, which is always bigger
than y equals arctan x.
And then they come in and right
at the origin, their tangent
to each other, they both
have derivative 1 here.
And then for negative
x, and then they cross.
And so arctan x is larger
than x is larger than tan x
when x is less than 0.
So that was all I wanted
to share with you,
just this slightly
cleaner picture
of the arctan of x that I get
by being able to put it up
on the board ahead of time.
So that's that.